في زياره اولى منذ اعاده انتخابه لولايه
رئاسيه ثالثه وصل الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
وهذه الزياره قد تحدد مستقبل حرب اوكرانيا
تقول هنا صحيفه روسيه حرب اوكرانيا حاضره
بقوه على طاوله النقاش بين الزعيمين
الصيني والروسيه تستعد لمضاعفه الدور في
الصراع في الوقت الذي تحدثت فيه طبعا
الولايات المتحده عن ان الصين ستبدا
بارسال امدادات عسكريه الى موسكو وحذرت من
ذلك ولكن الامر لا يتعلق بتسليم اسلحه كما
يعتقد الامريكيون بل برغبه بكين في ان
تصبح وسيطا في صنع السلام بعدما حققت
نجاحا مهما بالاتفاق الاخير بين كل من
ايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه حسب طبعا
الصحيفه الروسيه الرئيس الصيني يمكن ان
يقدم بديلا مختلفا وضمانات مختلفه وفق هذه
المبادره التي فرصه جديده لتحقيق السلام
من جانب اخر الرئيس الصيني يمتلك بعض
اسلحه الضغط على الجانب الاوكراني وعلى
راسها احتمالات امداد روسيا بالاسلحه هنا
مسؤولون الصينيون قالوا للصحيفه الروسيه
لماذا يمكن للغرب ان يصلح تايوان ولا يمكن
للصين تزويد روسيا بالاسلحه ولماذا لا
تجعل بكين التعاون العسكري مع موسكو
مرتبطا بشكل مباشر بقضيه تايوان وفي حال
فعل تفصيل ذلك فانه سيشكل اخبارا واخبارا
سيئه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا لانه اذا كان على
واشنطن ان تختار بين دعم كياف وتعيبي فان
الامريكيين سيختارون تايبي بالتاكيد وذلك
لانها هي قصه اقدم بكثير واكثر اهميه
بالنسبه لهم هذا الامر بحسب ايضا الصحيفه
سيدفع كياف الى التفكير بطريقه جديه وتبدا
هنا المشاورات مع موسكو وبناء عليه ستكون
ضربه قاسيه للغرب وسياساته
وفيعطي هذا الصين مكانه جديده بوصفها
صانعه للسلام العالمي والحديث هنا طبعا
للصحيفه الروسيه